on s'affaire dans les salles du château
quelques professionnels sont au travail
pour la partie technique mais
l'essentiel de la troupe est constituée
de bénévoles près de 800 au total lancé
dans un incroyable marathon
leur mission consistait à effectuer sept
cent cinquante représentations du
fabuleux noël du château en quatre
week-ends un exploit accompli grâce à la
totale adhésion du groupe
c'est une aventure assez assez
extraordinaire et puis ça permet de se
dépasser
ça permet de ce fait de fédérer les gens
entre eux d'avoir une continuité de
faire vivre le chaton aussi parce que
c'est un peu une belle envie un château
comme ça c'est c'est le château qui sont
en rayon il s'est endormi et là on
l'arrêt depuis quatre ans il
[Musique]
le château de match
le spectacle d'environ une heure évoque
la vie de madame de maintenon favorite
du roi louis xiv le roi soleil lui
octroya la somme nécessaire à l'achat du
château de maintenant en 16 174 et en
fit secrètement son épouse en 16 183
cette trajectoire étonnante et compter
dans ce spectacle pour petits et grands
dont le château de maintenant est à la
fois l'écrin est la vedette
le château de maintenon il intervient
assez tard dans la vie madame de main
puisqu'elle l'acquiert quand elle est
déjà introduite à la cour c est ici qu
elle va venir elle va il se resserre de
nombreux travaux avant la montespan va
accoucher de certains enfants de louis
xiv
donc en fait le château de maintenon et
là comme un coq comme un fil historique
de l'histoire qu'on raconte tableau
ce spectacle existe depuis 2015 et à
trouver son public
chaque hiver il attire près de 20000
visiteurs ce qui en fait l'événement
culturel majeur du département
d'eure-et-loir en fin d'année
[Musique]